[Music]
my administration is putting an end to
the war on coal bringing back our jobs
bringing back our dreams gonna have
clean called
really clean call this is the clean coal
the US president was referring to and
while Germany pushes ahead with its
nuclear phase-out the mining of anything
but clean brown coal ore lignite is
still in demand but does the country
really need coal as it expands its
renewable energy sector or does
President Trump have a point in the
Loess its coal mining region in eastern
Germany opinion is deeply divided
Wolfgang who PIPA is among those who
defend lignite mining he says there are
still too many unresolved energy issues
to phase out fossil fuel the annoyer ban
Inuk currently renewables cannot deliver
a secure supply of electricity at an
affordable price for both households and
industry we still need lignite power
plants to meet demand for landscape
planner sebastian took the switch to
wind and Sun power can't come soon
enough
he wants more sustainability and the
energy supply now pick up the stuff say
fish I'm confident that by 2030 we will
no longer need coal I think by then
it'll be politically and economically
unviable around 60 million tons of
lignite our mind at the Loews its region
every year
there are regular protests against the
environmental impact and entire villages
have been relocated to make way for new
opencast mines but could Germany simply
turn off its coal-fired power plants in
2016 lignite accounted for some 40
percent of Germany's total energy
generation around the same proportion as
renewable sources we'll have to see how
energy consumption evolves when the
government wants to phase out the use of
fossil fuels by 2050 the question is
then obviously how are you going to fill
that gap our lighting technology will be
far more energy efficient and our
heating - so there alone you have a huge
energy saving potential Putin's our coal
mining is one of the few industries left
and allows its region it might not have
made local communities rich but it did
guarantee them an income today around
12,000 jobs here are directly or
indirectly connected to coal leaving
many fearful of a phase-out Germany's
lignite mining workforce is a fraction
of what it used to be the industry
League your luck would mean the end of
industry allows it at the end of a 100
year tradition basically it would
devastate the region a concern not
shared by anti-coal activists they point
to the many new jobs created by
renewable energies to date already
375,000 in Germany in mention if you
invest four decades in a fossil energy
source that's not exactly famed for its
future viability then it's hardly
surprising when young forward-looking
people are turned off and decide to
leave the region but none and for a
preview of that post coal future this
former mine on the outskirts of cut boss
was shut down in December 2015 it's now
being transformed into what will soon be
one of the biggest lakes in Germany